hi my name is Michael Kearney shop for
corn and I am one of the cofounders of
school share hi my name is Malcolm um
one of the cofounders of Skillshare
school search started about two years
ago I was playing in a huge poker
tournament call the World Series of
Poker in order to increase my chances of
winning I got a lot of the best poker
players to teach me in a play so long
story short when I got back to New York
all my friends asked me to teach him
everything I learned and that it
eventually became the first school story
class
yeah skill shows unique in a way that we
really focus on the community and we
really believe that anyone could be
teacher and anyone can become students
the business model behind skills share
is pretty simple we take a 15%
transaction fee out of every ticket that
gives sold for a class but what we're
really trying to instill is new ways of
teaching so for example being able to
learn from peer to peer and other
students as well or doing homework in
person or workshops to person so a lot
of things we're doing internally is
thinking about that and some new
teaching and learning models we could
implement it for the business we're
really focused on scaling to achieve a
vision for what we believe education
should be in the future